[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sciences publiques
votre rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat ce soir c'est une émission
spéciale que je vous propose après 10
jours de débats intense sur la réforme
des retraites le texte vous le savez a
été voté samedi soir et pour le chef des
sénateurs LR c'est une victoire c'est
une victoire du Sénat parce que nous
avons pu voter le métier d'un
parlementaire le rôle du Parlement c'est
pas de discuter à l'infini le Sénat en
ressort grandi les parlementaires les
sénateurs ont pu voter pour ou contre
peu importe mais ils ont voté qui a
gagné cette bataille au terme de 109
heures d'échange souvent électrique
cette réforme coécrite par LR et le
gouvernement Marketel une nouvelle ère
dans le second quinquennat Macron on en
débattra juste après ces titres et puis
dans 45 minutes on va se projeter sur
cette semaine décisive pour Elisabeth
borne la première ministre pourra-t-elle
éviter d'utiliser l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution pour faire passer le report
de las Vega à 64 ans la commission mixte
paritaire peut-elle faire évoluer le
texte mercredi alors que des centaines
de milliers de Français manifesteront
pour la 8e fois qu'elle sera justement
la stratégie des syndicats et notamment
de la CFDT si la réforme est votée
réponse tout à l'heure mais d'abord on
résume le texte adopté dans la soirée de
samedi avec Fabien Ricard pour 195
contre 112 le Sénat a adopté en adoptant
la réforme des retraites le Sénat
entérine le report de l'âge de départ à
64 ans une mesure chair à la droite
sénatoriale qui l'a proposé depuis
plusieurs années parmi les autres
apports de la Haute Assemblée la surcote
pour les maires de famille celle qui a
63 ans auront une carrière complète
partiront tout de même à 64 ans mais
pour cette année supplémentaire chaque
trimestre sera majoré pour une surcote
totale de 5% maximum les troupes de
brunes ont retaillaux en faisait une
condition de leur soutien à une réforme
cette mesure avait été à l'époque
raillée par la gauche qui voyait comment
dirais-je un vieux réflexe de la droite
réactionnaire d'une politique nataliste
et avec cette amendement on n'a pas eu
une seule voix contre donc bien sûr les
maires de famille on veut les valoriser
avec cette surcote c'est elle qui
tiennent aussi l'équilibre de notre
système démographique autre rapport du
Sénat le CDI senior voté contre la vie
du gouvernement il doit favoriser
l'embauche des plus de 60 ans leur
employeur sera exonéré de cotisations
familiales la mesure est assortie d'un
index senior sur le modèle de l'égalité
femme homme les entreprises de plus de
300 salariés devront communiquer sur la
part de seniors dans leurs effectifs des
ajustements au texte porté par la droite
mais pour la gauche le compte n'y est
toujours pas encore une diminution de
cotisations sociales pour les
entreprises donc nous n'avons pas voté
ici au Sénat mais en tout cas c'est une
mesure qui montre que la copie du
gouvernement est très insuffisante
puisqu'elle recule l'âge de la retraite
sans s'attaquer à cette question du
chômage des seniors qui aurait dû être
traité en priorité autre évolution sur
la question des carrières longues la
version du Sénat prévoit des départs
anticipés 63 ans pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler à 20 ans 60 ans
pour les travailleurs déclarés inapte
après un accident du travail ou une
maladie professionnelle parmi les autres
rapports de la chambre haute un malus
pour les parents condamnés pour
maltraitance ou encore des trimestres
supplémentaires pour les pompiers
volontaires reste à savoir si ces
modifications au texte du Gouvernement
seront retenus par la commission mixte
paritaire qui doit rédiger mercredi une
version finale de la réforme des
retraites
le premier débat de ce sens public je
vous présente mes invités Catherine
tricot bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous
êtes directrice de la revue regard
Franck Morel bonsoir et bienvenue à
avocat associé chez Flichy Grangé ancien
conseiller social d'Édouard Philippe à
Matignon et expert emploi à l'Institut
Montaigne Olivier Rozenberg bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi professeur au
Centre d'études européenne et de
politique comparée à Sciences Po et
j'accueille Guillaume d'arrêt bonsoir
Guillaume politique bienvenue à vous on
va démarrer sur le contenu de cette
réforme Catherine tricot quand vous avez
vu Olivier du socle le ministre du
Travail dire je crois que c'était à la
une de nos confrères du Parisien
Aujourd'hui en France il y a une dizaine
de jours c'est une réforme de gauche
comment vous avez réagi
ça veut rien dire enfin tout le monde
sait bien que ce n'est pas une réforme
de gauche c'est qu'elle a été obtenue
par négociation avec la droite avec les
républicains et qu'elles portent
régression par rapport aux acquis
sociaux tout le monde le sait donc
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire la gauche
elle ne veut ça n'a plus aucun sens je
pense que Olivier du socle qui lui vient
à gauche veut se raconter une histoire
qui lui permet de continuer de penser
qu'il est fidèle à lui-même mais ce
n'est pas le cas et d'ailleurs c'est
bien ce qui est en jeu dans cette
affaire c'est que c'est une vécue par
les Français comme une régression
sociale et la gauche ne porte pas les
régressions sociales alors on va ensuite
détailler certaines des mesures qui ont
été adoptées mais j'aurais bien voulu
vous entendre peut-être un avis général
sur la réforme telle qu'elle existe pour
l'instant on sait qu'elle va peut-être
être modifiée en commission mix
paritaire bon Franck Morel régression
sociale nous dit Catherine triko
évidemment on va pas être d'accord sur
le terme régression sociale quand on
veut sauver le régime de retraite par
répartition je l'appelle pas ça une
régression sociale au contraire c'est
effectivement le fait de faire en sorte
que ce régime de retraite par
répartition soit viable de manière
durable alors le texte il a évolué au
Sénat ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure on
verra ce qu'il en est effectivement au
sortir de la commission mixte paritaire
mais grosso modo le gouvernement a
plutôt réussi à maintenir le cap sur
l'essentiel des mesures du texte avec
somme toute quand même une difficulté
sur le fait que on était à peu près au
tiers des économies qui étaient générées
par la réforme au début qui était
consommée par des mesures compensatoires
sur les carrières longues notamment on
est monté sans doute pas loin des 50 %
et donc il y a effectivement un certain
nombre de voies qui se sont élevés pour
indiquer que et bien le compte y était
sans doute pas en termes d'économie
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que Bruno
Retailleau avait proposé d'intégrer les
régimes spéciaux en faisant sauter la
clause du grand-père et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'Olivier du soft dans l'une
des dernières interviews qu'il a fait
indiqué que il y aurait sans doute dans
le PLFSS ou dans le PLFR dans le PLF à
venir en fin d'année encore quelques
économies nécessaires pour boucler la
boucle sur l'équation budgétaire globale
Olivier Rosenberg réforme de droite ou
de gauche si les mots ont encore un sens
pour reprendre ce que c'est je vais être
prudent c'est une réforme alors comme
l'a dit ma voisine négociait avec la
droite ça fait aucun doute et négocier
de façon substantielle
le milliard d'euros qui sont le fruit de
cette négociation qui sait pas fait avec
la gauche qui s'est fait avec la la
droite c'est aussi une réforme qui
au-delà de son contenu une dimension
doublement symbolique et
la symbolique est pas perçue de la même
chose la même façon à droite à gauche
d'abord un symbolique de volontarisme de
la part de Macron qui veut laisser
l'image peut-être le leg historique de
quelqu'un qui a essayé de faire des
choses qui essayait d'en perdre d'en
payer le prix en termes de popularité et
puis aussi symbolique vis-à-vis des
institutions financières des agences de
notation qui sont en train d'estimer
comme toujours la crédibilité financière
de la France et à qui on peut dire vous
voyez on va au maximum des réformes
possibles le la rue la rue est debout
donc on essaie vraiment de tenir une
même j'ai posé la question aux
présidentielles la semaine dernière sur
ce plateau je lui ai donné ces arguments
là mais c'est de toute façon les les 13
milliards de la réforme ça pèse rien par
rapport aux déficit de la France donc si
on disait faux arguments mais je vous
parle de symbole dire que c'est ces
agences qui sont aussi sensibles au
message donc le message c'est on essaie
de faire des messages de courage
politique je je
quoi qu'il en coûte est terminé et que
maintenant à faire attention à ce qu'on
dépense et puis ça peut influer sur les
taux d'intérêt qui sont applicables
justement à notre dette c'est aussi un
élément assez considérable par rapport à
la durabilité de la possibilité de faire
des réformes dans notre pays dans la
contestation quand même de cette réforme
il y avait à la fois le financement
puisqu'en fait on avait décidé qu'on ne
que ça serait financé uniquement par les
salariés donc c'est que eux qui font
l'effort et deuxièmement ce qu'on peut
aussi se dire c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres choses à faire pour
mettre notre pays à flot et que ce n'est
pas fait qu'on a privilégié une réforme
qui est relativement mineure par rapport
à tous les enjeux qui sont ceux de la
transition énergétique de l'hôpital de
l'école de l'armée etc etc il y a
énormément de choses qui font que notre
pays se sent fragilisé et que la
population se sent à l'impression d'un
pays qui dégringole et que c'est pas ça
qu'on s'est attaqué donc ça pose un vrai
problème de message
vis-à-vis de la population et même
vis-à-vis de nos partenaires européens
et institutionnels
laissera des traces dans l'opinion cette
réforme évidemment qu'elle laissera des
traces dans l'opinion comme les
précédentes très formes ont laissé des
traces dans l'opinion quand on regarde
au cours de dans le rétroviseur au cours
des 20 30 dernières années aucune
réforme des retraites ne s'est fait dans
la joie et la bonne humeur ça a toujours
été quelque chose de douloureux de
difficile j'ai souvenir de la réforme
des retraites de 2010 par exemple il y
avait eu 14 manifestations dont quatre
qui ont dépassé le million il y a eu des
étudions
il y a eu des débats extrêmement houleux
à l'Assemblée le président de
l'Assemblée nationale à l'époque avait
été poursuivi jusque dans dans les
locaux de l'hôtel de lacet par
l'opposition à l'époque donc quand on se
remémore effectivement ce qui s'est
passé à cette époque on regarde les
débats à l'Assemblée avec un prisme un
petit peu différent parce que ça a
toujours été compliqué en revanche il
faut souligner une chose quand même ça a
été compliqué en 2010 ça a été compliqué
en 2003 mais alors même que la France a
connu plusieurs alternances au cours des
dernières années personne n'est revenu
sur les réformes des retraites il y
avait été initié à l'époque bien
qu'elles étaient nécessaires qu'elles
étaient indispensables et puis je peux
vous faire un pari aujourd'hui je fais
le pari qu'il est fort vraisemblable que
personne malgré tout ce qui est dit en
ce moment que personne ne reviendra sur
la réforme des retraites qui va
probablement être adoptée dans Marine Le
Pen elle le dit elle reviendra dessus si
elle était liée à la présidence de la
République après elle disait il y a
quelques semaines qu'elle ne serait plus
candidate à la présidence de la
République on verra évidemment il y a
des paroles qui sont mises sur la table
et on voit bien effectivement la
stratégie qui est logique d'ailleurs
dans son cas de poser tout de suite et
être la première à le faire de poser cet
acte mais on verra ce qu'il en est je
peux vous dire qu'on regarde de
l'histoire de des précédentes réforme
des retraites et de tout ce qui s'est
passé malgré les différentes alternances
c'est un pari qui peut qui peut avoir
des chances d'être rempli je vous donne
la parole juste après Catherine tr mais
je voudrais vous entendre peut-être sur
la tonalité des débats les Rosenberg ils
ont été ici au Sénat plus peut-être plus
dur plus électrique que prévu est-ce que
ça vous a surpris ça
m'a un peu surpris parce que le Sénat et
le Sénat joue beaucoup de ça de dans son
image de marque dans sa société de
communication sur l'idée que c'est une
assemblée où on prend son temps on s'est
écouté ou on fait pas de la politique
Babette alors certes ils sont arrivés au
bout de l'examen ce qui était un enjeu
symbolique très fort on l'a vu dans le
dans le dans ce que disait Bruno
Retailleau en même temps il y a eu aussi
des de l'attention alors on va éviter
entre sénateurs de ce traité d'assassin
comme on a vu à l'Assemblée mais il y a
eu de l'Ascension y compris sur la le
bien fondé de l'utilisation de certaines
tactiques procédurales type vlog bloqué
ou l'article qui permet de clôturer
rapidement les les débats ça m'a un peu
surpris de voir que même au Sénat on
pouvait avoir cette tension et en même
temps ça aurait donné un peu de valeur
politique au Sénat aussi parce qu'on
nous disait tellement ça allait être
quelque part tranquille mais que il y a
les pas se passer grand chose pendant
une semaine
moi je pense que ça a presque
probablement aussi servile c'est non
disant que c'était une vraie chambre ou
hyper un vrai débat politique également
Catherine tricot vous dites que que ce
qui s'est passé finalement cette semaine
au Sénat ça marque une peut-être une
nouvelle séquence dans le quinquennat le
second quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
pourquoi ah oui parce que moi je suis le
sentiment que là on clou le discours le
storytelling sur le en même temps c'est
normal en même temps de gauche et en
même temps de droite là on est de droite
et on a négocié avec la droite et donc
là je pense que ça va
redistribuer absolument toutes les
cartes politiques la gauche se retrouve
maintenant de voir d'adresser un regard
un message à l'égard des électeurs
d'Emmanuel Macron qui pour pratiquement
la moitié d'entre eux venez de la gauche
et qui vont aujourd'hui être vraiment
orphelin c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne vont pas
continuer de soutenir une politique qui
est aussi manifestement de droite et par
ailleurs à droite je pense que le disque
le débat va être assez vif pour savoir
si la droite a un espace distinct de
celui d'Emmanuel Macron et est-ce que
cet espace peut être autre chose que du
libéralisme
pur de sucre comme celui que fait
Emmanuel Macron et qu'il est en ce sens
vous avez bien raison tout à fait dans
la suite de ce qui s'est passé
précédemment depuis ces 30 dernières
années donc là il y a quelque chose qui
à mon avis entre une bascule politique
qui
réagir à ça mais d'abord on écoute
le sénateur écologiste Thomas dessus sur
le finalement la stratégie des trois
parties de gauche au Sénat pendant ces
10 jours de débat on a fait on a mené la
bataille plus de senteurs 109 heures de
débats ici on était très présent on a
essayé par tous les moyens d'expliquer
la brutalité de la réforme l'injustice
de cette réforme le caractère sa forme
les façons de faire autrement aussi on a
expliqué puisque on n'a pas pu en
débattre avec le reste de du Sénat
puisque la droite a décidé d'être assez
mythique dans les débats puis d'activer
tout ce que tout ce qu'elle pouvait pour
contraindre les droits d'expression de
l'opposition de nous
donc aujourd'hui ben voilà on arrive au
conclusions attendues de ce débat le
Sénat majorité d'une droite très
conservatrice a voté cette réforme
Franck Morel est-ce que c'est une
nouvelle ère qui démarre dans le
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron bah c'est
sûr peut-être alliance on y est pas hein
mais non l'alliance non c'est sûr que la
question de la presse va être
particulièrement importante parce que
l'ensemble des partis prenantes vont
sortir de la séquence
avec dans une situation compliquée le
gouvernement parce que effectivement il
aura à cœur assez rapidement de passer à
autre chose et d'envoyer des gages sur
toute une série d'autres sujets
peut-être pour équilibrer par rapport à
la question gauche-droite
les partenaires sociaux parce que il y
aura sans doute potentiellement une
forme d'amertume qui pourra exister par
rapport à un certain nombre de je dirais
de de d'acteurs qui ont espéré
effectivement le retrait le retrait du
texte et donc la difficulté c'est qu'il
va falloir
enchanté d'une certaine manière je suis
pas si c'est le bon terme mais en tout
cas recoller les morceaux on va dire
avec d'une part les partenaires sociaux
alors dans le champ social il y a la loi
qui va donner corps aux assises du
travail au préconisations des Assises du
travail et à la mise en œuvre de
l'alcool national interprofessionnel sur
le partage de la valeur et à la mise en
place de France travail qui va donner du
grain à moudre
de la à considérer que c'est le grand
dessin qui va permettre de renouer les
liens avec le syndic les syndicats on en
est pas là effectivement on en est loin
je veux une parenthèse c'est pas gagné
notamment avec la CFD
qui le dit même d'ailleurs face caméra
pas seulement en coulisses C'est il
faudra pas venir nous chercher justement
sur cette fameuse loi travail du mieux
travailler du bien travailler dont on
parle déjà le gouvernement
Philippe Martinez par le carrément lui
d'un bras d'honneur on l'a vu dans les
manifestations samedi après ne pas avoir
été reçus par Emmanuel Macron donc la
suite avec les syndicats ça va être très
compliqué ça va être compliqué après si
je fais le Para encore une fois avec
avec 2010 qui avait été aussi une
séquence extrêmement compliquée avec
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
déjà à l'époque qui était qui était
opposé à la réforme il y a quand même eu
en 2011 une réforme importante de la
formation professionnelle qui qui
s'était mise en place avec des
discussions avec les partenaires sociaux
donc il y a toujours la possibilité en
prenant le temps qu'il faut en ayant les
bons sujets effectivement en envoyant un
certain nombre de signaux de retisser du
lien mais je ressens aujourd'hui les
syndicats au gouvernement et au
président de la République c'est
l'absence de lien et de contact y
compris durant cette période c'est à
dire que tous les syndicats et tous les
anciens ministres des gouvernements pour
lesquels vous avez travaillé disent on a
toujours maintenu une forme de lien par
des conseillers que ce soit l'Élysée ou
à Matignon et là ils étaient totalement
inexistants alors est-ce que les liens
étaient totalement inexistants j'en suis
pas convaincu je sais par exemple qu'à
Matignon il y a quelqu'un qui est là
justement pour faire le Goby twin et
puis aller voir régulièrement les
organisations professionnelles et
syndicales ce qui est certain c'est que
sur les liens interpersonnels et là je
parle pas des conseillers je parle des
du président de la République et des
leaders c'est plus compliqué ça c'est
clair et ça s'est vu donc ça va prendre
du temps ça va prendre du temps parce
que il faudra justement échanger avoir
des sujets qui sont plus simples sur
lesquels échanger qui dépasse d'ailleurs
le champ social on parlait tout à
l'heure de la transition écologique il y
aura sans doute un certain nombre de
choses à faire je sais pas si le
président va se lancer dans le chantier
institutionnel qui est un chantier
extrêmement périlleux aussi et qui est
pas présenté comme faisant partie des
préoccupations majeures de nos
concitoyens mais en tout cas
effectivement il va falloir occuper le
terrain et recréer du lien avec les
acteurs c'est pas impossible ça va
prendre du temps mais c'est pas
impossible Olivier rodenberg votre avis
là-dessus et peut-être sur finalement le
là on fait un peu le bilan de de cette
semaine au Sénat mais de ce qu'il en
ressort sur le fond du texte mais aussi
effectivement sur l'image du président
de la République sa capacité d'action
sur la fin de son quinqu ainsi si cette
planche est à ce point savonneuse de ces
relations avec les les partenaires
sociaux notamment ça va être compliqué
d'un point de vue parlementaire et
politique les fondamentaux restent là
c'est à dire que le gouvernement n'a pas
de majorité absolue et donc doit
négocier au milieu de l'abstention voire
des soutiens et les partenaires avec qui
peut le faire restent les mêmes sauf que
la situation est plus compliquée parce
que la gauche
il y a une fracture durable avec la
gauche mais la droite va avoir à cœur de
montrer pour pas être satellisé pour
garder une entité politique propre de
hacker de montrer qu'ils savent
s'opposer aux macronisme sur d'autres
sujets il y a une loi par exemple sur
l'immigration qui va venir porter par
par le ministre Darmanin qui commence à
être examiné au Sénat on peut s'attendre
à des difficultés pour pour la faire
passer parce que la droite veut montrer
que elle a une raison d'être après ça en
revanche par rapport je vous suis sur ce
qui était dit sur le fait qu'on pourrait
avoir des surprises du côté de la
négociation sociale et des lois sociales
pour une autre raison qui est que le des
manifestations a surpris la classe
politique peut-être même les syndicats
qu'elle révèle une profonde mal-être au
travail de beaucoup de gens c'est aussi
pour ça qu'il manifeste qui sont pas
heureux dans leur dans leur travail et
je crois que cette prise de conscience
de nos de nos élites politiques
devraient se traduire par une volonté de
d'agir sur ce sujet là alors on dans
notre bilan de cette de ces 10 jours de
d'examen de la réforme ici au Sénat avec
Steve Jourdain qui va nous rejoindre sur
ce plateau on a on sait entre guillemets
amusé c'est foncé on peut dire ça comme
ça à regarder qui qui les élus qui sont
un peu sortis du lot car tu dois retenu
votre attention la palme de l'endurance
est décerné à l'écologie c'est Raymonde
poncemont je sais pas moi qui attribue
les prix Thomas c'est un jury
complètement objectif complètement
impartial je vous présente le sénateur
sans triste Olivier Hainaut
vous avez travaillé je dirais même que
si c'était à la quantité de salive et
d'encre il faudrait donner le maillot
jaune à Madame ponce
de de la salive oui parce que Raymond
ponceron j'avais effectivement beaucoup
pris la parole au nom du groupe
écologiste c'est là défendu pas moins de
564 amendements à la louche sur plus de
100 heures de débats on a fait le calcul
la sénatrice pourrait avoir atteint les
cinq heures de temps de parole effective
c'est beaucoup on rappelle que le groupe
écolo au Sénat c'est seulement 12
sénateurs sur 348 alors 5 heures c'est
beaucoup mais elle aurait mis en faire
plus écouter là
je vais rapidement parce que la vitesse
ou la majorité y compris le rapporteur
retire leurs amendements j'avais peur
d'être interrompu avant la fin de mes
deux minutes et vous savez l'intérêt que
j'ai à vous parler donc au moins là
c'est bon je peux aller jusqu'à deux
minutes c'est bien alors il y a d'autres
élus qui ont tirer leur épingle du jeu
évidemment
particulier a été en première ligne pour
défendre les 64 ans il s'agit du trait
flegmatique René Paul Savary le
rapporteur LR de la branche viess sur la
réforme des retraites enfin flemmatic
oui mais faut pas le chercher écoutez-le
il y a des violences des violences du
débat parlementaire vous
n’être amendement vous profitez de la
tribune pour faire des effets tribunes
parce que vous savez qu'on vous regarde
et effectivement les gens nous regardent
voilà et puis quand ça tend quand la
température commence à monter dans
l'hémicycle la droite a parfois besoin
de montrer bah qu'elle se laisse pas
faire quel est le vrai maître des
horloges ici au Sénat et c'est à ce
moment là qu'entre en jeu l'expérimenté
Roger caoutchi qui intervient
régulièrement pour en quelque sorte
climatisé la salle je me permets de dire
à Monsieur chanterelle et à l'ensemble
de nos collègues que si le climat
restait celui-là il faudrait appliquer
la totalité du règlement et dans la
totalité du règlement monsieur Chantrel
il y a un article 95 qui dit très
clairement que toute provocation toute
atteinte à la présidence de séance
entraîne la censure voir l'exclusion du
Sénat
climatisait ça c'est une expression de
fan de football ça c'est un but de
Mbappé au stade Vélodrome c'est de cette
de ce niveau là bon à l'occasion de
l'examen de cette réforme il y a eu
aussi une star un peu inattendue oui
c'est un article du règlement du Sénat
l'article 38 qui permet de limiter le
temps de parole par article ou par
amendement il limite le temps de jeu en
quelque sorte Thomas c'est un dispositif
qui n'avait jamais été utilisé à la
Chambre haute il a été introduit en 2015
il a déboulé en majesté mardi dernier au
moment de l'examen du recul de la
retraite à 64 ans au total il a été
utilisé à six reprises par la majorité
pendant les débats et tout le monde ne
l'a pas accueilli de la même manière
café 5 jours et 5 nuits que nous avons à
faire à une obstruction je voudrais dire
que l'OB
struction du Parlement bien sûr le rôle
du Parlement c'est de débattre mais de
débattre pour voter on a été lu non pas
pour faire des groupes de parole mais
pour voter honte à vous
vous êtes laissés bâillonner par le 47 1
de la Constitution et le gouvernement et
vous voulez maintenant bâillonner votre
opposition c'est un scandale
voilà en résumait beaucoup de découverte
quelques confirmations à l'occasion de
cet examen au Sénat les palmes et les
récompenses sont remises en jeu dès
aujourd'hui Thomas puisque la loi
immigration arrive cette semaine au
Sénat tout le monde est chaude tout le
monde est dans les starting blocks merci
beaucoup Steve journal
cette nuit les Oscars quand même très
bon film qui a été largement récompensé
je vais pas me risquer à redire le titre
un mot du vote bloqué quand même parce
que vous l'avez évoqué rapidement tout à
l'heure mais est-ce que c'est pas ça
nous emmènera mais on y parlera on en
parlera plutôt vers la fin de cette
première partie sur le l'éventualité
d'un 49-3 à l'Assemblée mais est-ce que
ça
délégitime pas en partie ce texte le
fait d'avoir dû passer par un vote
bloqué non non parce que clairement non
parce que tout le monde s'en fiche à
part nous le vote bloqué est une
procédure qui existe dans la
Constitution depuis 58 donc depuis
l'origine il est utilisé à l'Assemblée
nationale régulièrement peut-être cinq
fois par an depuis 1958 donc c'est pas
quelque chose qui apparaît là simplement
il y avait une un gentleman agrement au
Sénat pour dire comme au Sénat on
s'écoute on en a pas besoin on en a pas
besoin il se trouve que là pour une fois
le Sénat a fait comme l'Assemblée
nationale donc c'est pas en soi cette
procédure-là qui a d'ailleurs une
efficacité limitée qui
qui suffit à légitimer le débats
il y a une personnalité qui vous a
marqué Catherine tricot alors là on
retourne un petit peu plus loin en
arrière
c'est le ministre c'est sur notre
antenne c'est le ministre chargé des
Relations avec le Parlement fin janvier
on nous a demandé quel personnalité
quelle séquence finalement vous a vous a
frappé c'était Franck Riester face à Tam
traduit en l'écoute si vous reportez
l'âge légal elles sont évidemment un peu
pénalisés par ce report de l'âge légal
au nom dix convient absolument pas donc
les en revanche
elles sont un peu un peu plus impactés
du fait
sur ce point là particulier elles sont
un peu plus impactées que les hommes
évidemment de l'effet de la réforme sur
sur les femmes et l'inégalité pourquoi
vous c'est un moment de vérité en
quelque sorte je m'amuse parce qu'en
fait j'étais là les mots n'ont plus de
sens mais c'est le un peu qui m'amuse
parce que là c'est elles sont un peu
impactées et on demande aux Français de
travailler un peu plus c'est-à-dire
qu'ils se rendent pas compte quoi que
deux ans c'est pas un peu plus et que
elles sont pas un peu impactées elles
sont beaucoup impactées puisque ça veut
dire qu'elles perdent le bénéfice des 8
trimestres qu'elles avaient obtenu pour
compenser le fait qu'elles ont des
carrières hachées etc et bon voilà il
est très Benoît enfin je dirais dit des
choses comme ça mais ils l'ont tous fait
de raconter des choses qui sont énormes
je veux dire les gens n'entendent pas du
tout que c'était un peu travaillé un peu
plus c'est c'est je crois qu'il y a une
espèce de de de monde irréel dans lequel
il y a une parole qui se balade et qui
n'a pas de rapport avec la réalité vous
parlez tout à l'heure de la difficulté
le fait que les Français ne sont pas
contents de leur travail il y a les
souffrances physiques on en a beaucoup
parler les critères de pénibilité qui
avait été supprimées par Emmanuel Macron
et qui n'ont pas été rétablis et qui ne
le sont toujours pas d'ailleurs mais il
y a aussi toute la souffrance
psychologique la certitude qu'on est
plus capable de le faire et ça mais ça
ne rentre pas dans le débat et je
voulais vous dire juste une toute petite
chose parce que je reprendrai peut-être
plus la parole à propos de toutes ces
lois qui ne sont jamais remises en cause
moi j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un
problème de sentiment de d'une France
qui qui s'affaisse et je vais vous dire
je pense qu'à l'échelle européenne c'est
la même question c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
on a une Europe on a une Europe qui n'a
plus d'allant qui n'est plus dans On
n'est plus on a plus de projet la seule
chose qu'on a à faire c'est d'essayer de
Tordre de tordre et là on va il faut
quand même qu'on se ressaisisse pour la
France et pour l'Europe il faut qu'on
arrive à retrouver de la lent et qu'on
arrive à redonner un espoir à une
perspective et c'est pas ce qui est en
train d'être fait et vous avez raison de
noter que cela n'a jamais été fait
depuis 30 ans non je voudrais réagir sur
le sur plusieurs points de ce que vous
venez de dire notamment sur le fait
soi-disant d'être une autre planète
précisément on n'est pas sur une autre
planète on est au milieu de pays
européens qui tous ont un âge à la fois
prescrit et réel de départ en retraite
qui est beaucoup plus élevé mais si
c'est vrai vous prenez l'âge moyen de
départ en retrait donc là
il est plus élevé en Europe qu'il ne
l'est dans tous les pays d'Europe non ne
l'est en France par ailleurs par
ailleurs quand on regardera quand on
comparera le temps réel passé à la
retraite après la réforme par rapport au
temps réel passé à la retraite dans
d'autres pays européens on sera en bonne
santé de très loin on sera encore de
très loin parmi les pays européens ou ce
temps même le pays européen ou ce temps
est le plus élevé donc ça c'est quand
même des éléments factuels exacts
veulent pas il le manifeste parce qu'ils
n'en veulent pas parce qu'ils veulent
avoir le droit de dire ce que je suis en
train de dire vous avez le droit de le
dire mais non mais vous vous dites que
c'est des choses factuelles est-ce que
je vous fais vous n'entendez pas ce qui
vous est dit totalitarisme intellectuel
a refusé bien sûr effectivement un
certain nombre de faits ou non
d'arguments de nature émotionnelle qui
se qualifierait inévitablement tout ce
qui a été vous parliez des facteurs de
pénibilité qui ont été supprimés en 2017
on savait les mesurer il y a eu 5
rapports d'expertise pendant le
quinquennat Hollande qui a pollué
complètement tout le quinquennat
Hollande et qui a fait qu'on ne pouvait
pas appliquer les fameux critères de
pénibilités de pénibilité oui ou non
la question c'était pas de savoir si
c'est un facteur pénibilité c'était de
savoir si on pouvait appliquer
concrètement dans les entreprises le
fait donc on a supprimés on a choisi de
le compenser d'une autre manière qui
était bien meilleure qui était en train
de libération
des critères médicaux et ça c'est
quelque chose de concret et donc c'est
évidemment très facile très émotionnel
de dire les facteurs de pénibilité ils
ont été on ne retient pas le fait que ça
n'était pas applicable c'était des
garanties de papier c'était pas des
garanties concrètes réelles et ce qui a
été fait en 2017 c'est précisément sur 6
facteurs de les garder parce que cela on
savait les mesurer et sur les autres de
renvoyer un certain nombre de
dispositifs d'une autre nature dans le
plan qui a été mis en place dans le plan
qu'elle était présentée très rapidement
il y a des mesures de prévention de
l'usure le vrai sujet c'est pas la
compensation c'est la prévention de
l'usure c'est faire en sorte à travers
un certain nombre de dispositifs qu'on
puisse sortir quelqu'un d'une situation
de pénibilité
on passe à la politique et les LR non
non mais c'est juste ce que je pense
c'est que par exemple la maladie on dit
que c'est des médecins qui doivent le
déclarer vous savez très bien qu'on a
tellement de mal à faire reconnaître les
maladies professionnelles vous ne savez
donc tous les gens vivent tout ce qui se
passe comme une régression et comme le
fait qu'on demande je redis on demande
au même à ceux qui ont les travaux les
plus durs de travailler plus longtemps
d'une façon qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire
et pendant ce temps on ne demande rien à
ceux qui ont engrangé des bénéfices
exceptionnels
je voudrais on reste un peu sur le fond
du du taxi le voulait bien lui dire
Rosenberg peut-être sur la perspective
du Conseil constitutionnel parce que on
sait que bon il y aura forcément un
recours et qui a une peut-être certains
articles qui seront retoqués par le
Conseil est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
lesquels dès aujourd'hui oui on peut
imaginer en fait le véhicule législatif
qui a été choisi c'est un projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificatif donc ça veut dire qu'on
prévoit bien des finances des dépenses
et des et des recettes en l'occurrence
pas uniquement sur les finances et
potentiellement potentiellement
censurable dans ce cas là ce serait une
censure partielle ce serait l'article 2
peut-être sur l'index seniors l'article
3 sur sur des questions de de charges
sociales et
je pense que ce serait pas un si grand
revers pour le gouvernement d'une part
parce que l'essentiel c'est quand même
la mesure d'âge et d'autre bas parce
qu'il y aura d'autres occasions à
commencer par les les autres lois de
finances d'introduire ces critères-là
enfin c'est dispositions là donc
finalement c'est pas c'est pas si grave
allez on parle des LR avec vous
Guillaume on l'a vu et on l'a dit au
combien sur ce plateau depuis plusieurs
jours ils ont joué ils jouent un rôle
central dans aussi des retraites est-ce
que ça peut marquer l'amorce d'un
redressement pour le Parti vert c'est
sûr qu'on a quand même le sentiment que
ça leur a permis ce dossier de revenir
sur le devant de la scène et un ministre
qui est pas issu des républicains qui me
disaient la semaine dernière ça a marqué
le retour de la droite républicaine de
la droite de gouvernement dans le débat
politique et on l'a vu effectivement
parce qu'ils ont réussi quand même
quasiment à imposer leurs conditions à
chaque fois qu'ils le souhaitent et
quand ils ont demandé quelque chose à
Elisabeth borne quasiment à chaque fois
ils l'ont obtenu et en plus parfois ils
sont pas très bons mais là ils ont
plutôt bien su le mettre en scène en
matière de communication
ils ont su très bien s'appuyer sur le
travail qui avait été mené par la droite
sénatoriale ici depuis plusieurs années
notamment sur ce report de l'âge de
départ à la retraite et j'irai que
depuis 2017 on avait plutôt eu le
sentiment que c'était Emmanuel Macron
qui avait réussi à aspirer la droite et
ses valeurs vers lui là c'est plutôt la
droite qui a réussi à faire venir
Emmanuel Macron sur son terrain et c'est
plutôt réussi et c'était pourtant pas
gagné parce qu'ils partent quand même de
loin rappelez-vous moins de 5% à
l'élection présidentielle 61 députés
pour l'instant mais 61 députés qui
jouent un rôle absolument considérable
alors comment on peut expliquer cette
séquence alors évidemment pas un hasard
quand vous en parlez avec le patron du
parti Éric Ciotti là finement analysé
les choses et c'est intéressant parce
que avec ce petit il a plutôt l'image de
quelqu'un de l'aile droite des
républicains mais quand il a analysé la
situation il en a tiré une conviction
c'est que si les républicains veulent
être de retour à l'Élysée en 2027 il
leur faut reconquérir les électeurs de
droite et de centres droits qui sont
partis chez Emmanuel Macron il considère
que pour l'instant ceux qui sont partis
chez Marine Le Pen ça sera compliqué de
les récupérer dans un premier temps il
faut donc reconquérir ceux qui sont chez
Emmanuel Macron parce que c'est un
électorat qui va être si je veux dire
sur le marché en 2027 parce que Emmanuel
Macron pourra pas se représenter et donc
face à cette offre il y aura
probablement plusieurs candidats un
candidat issu de renaissance Bruno Le
Maire ou un autre probablement Édouard
Philippe et potentiellement aussi le
candidat des républicains que ce soit
Laurent Wauquiez ou un autre candidat et
donc sa conviction c'est que pour
réussir à faire revenir chez les
républicains ces électeurs là il faut
d'abord et avant tout être fidèle à ses
valeurs et fidèle à ses valeurs c'est
voté un texte pour lequel on a milité
depuis plusieurs années ok c'est
cohérent mais il y a encore du chemin à
faire il y a plus que du chemin à faire
parce que quand même quand on regarde ce
qui s'est passé on a vu aussi grâce à ce
dossier les failles parfois béantes qui
pourraient apparaître dans la
reconstruction de la façade des
républicains je dirais que la première
chose qui m'a marqué c'est quand même
ces deux nuances assez fortes entre la
droite de l'Assemblée nationale et la
droite du Sénat l'Assemblée avait plutôt
tendance du côté député avoir prendre
des mesures qui allait alourdir la
facture
ici même s'il y a eu la mesure
effectivement pour les mers de famille
les sénateurs voulaient plutôt on le
disait avec la question des régimes
spéciaux au contraire trouver des
sources d'économies ce qui m'a marqué
aussi c'est plus particulièrement pour
les députés l'absence totale de
discipline de groupe c'est à dire vous
avez aujourd'hui beaucoup de députés des
républicains qui considèrent qu'ils ne
doivent plus rien à personne pas même à
leur partie et que donc il y a pas
question de leur dire pour qui et
pourquoi il faudra voter ensuite et ça
met en lumière finalement encore le plus
grand manque des républicains 15 jours
c'est finalement l'absence de leader qui
aurait une autorité politique forte un
leadership for pour permettre et
finalement réussir à mettre tous ses
élus là derrière lui et derrière une
ligne au clair merci Guillaume il y a
pas mal de fil à tirer tranquille je
commence avec le effectivement c'est je
sais pas s'il faut employer le terme de
ligne de fracture mais quand même pas
loin entre les sénateurs LR et les
députés LR de l'autre comment vous
l'analysez quand vous l'expliquez ça le
premier élément d'explication c'est que
d'ailleurs Bruno le eurotaillod dans ces
éléments de langage l'a mis en avant a
dit c'est notre réforme qui vient d'être
votée je crois il a dit juste après par
le Sénat parce qu'effectivement
l'équilibre global de la réforme avec 64
ans et accélération de la réforme
Touraine c'est quelque chose qui de
longue date était mis en avant était
régulièrement votée par les sénateurs LR
au Sénat donc c'est un premier élément
de différenciation il y avait un côté du
côté lrcna à côté un peu appropriation
on va dire un côté ça y est on réussit
enfin à mettre en avant la réforme que
l'on appelait nos vœux depuis pas mal de
temps en revanche côté assemblé c'est un
peu différent parce que on est dans une
séquence beaucoup plus politisée entre
guillemets ou au-delà de l'analyse de la
réforme en tant que telle il y a eu tout
un débat au sein des républicains sur le
bon positionnement d'un point de vue
stratégique
vis-à-vis de cette réforme c'est à dire
entre les tenants de ceux qui
considéraient que c'était dans l'ADN de
la droite effectivement comme l'histoire
le démontre d'ailleurs de faire de
pousser un certain nombre de réformes
des retraites comme celle de 2010
précisément et puis un certain nombre
d'autres acteurs qui considéraient que
la droite voulait parler aux catégories
populaires et que pour parler aux
catégories populaires il fallait
forcément en passer par le fait de
s'opposer ou en tout cas d'être très
très exigeant
vis-à-vis de cette réforme des retraites
et il y a eu cette ligne de fracture
très forte à l'Assemblée beaucoup moins
forte au Sénat même si l'intégralité des
sénateurs LR n'ont pas voté la réforme
qui explique effectivement ça alors le
bilan pour les républicains vous l'avez
dit il est enduit teinte parce que d'un
côté ils ont été pivots ils ont été
central pour des raisons arithmétiques à
l'Assemblée parce qu'effectivement en
tant que groupe charnière pour dans un
contexte de majoritaire relative c'était
nécessaire d'avoir les voix des
républicains ils le seront encore jeudi
et ils le seront encore jeudi et donc la
question se posera 49-3 par 49-3 par
rapport à ça tire on me disait que
Elisabeth borne était toujours
particulièrement bienveillante à l'égard
des républicains évidemment à l'approche
du vote de jeudi dans le contexte que
vous venez de rappeler bien évidemment
et puis donc ça c'est pour le côté
positif alors en droit mais dans le côté
moins positif pour les républicains il y
a cette fracture effectivement cette
fracture que restera-t-il de cette
fracture après la séquence retraite et
puis toujours pareil est-ce que par-delà
le rôle central des républicains pendant
cette séquence et bien les républicains
ont réussi malgré tout à nouveau être
audible il y a des échéances extrêmement
périlleuses pour eux qui se présentent
l'an prochain les européennes par
exemple qui peuvent remettre de manière
assez brutale les compteurs à zéro de ce
point de vue là Olivier rodenda j'avais
demandé à chacun d'entre vous de choisir
une personnalité un peu marquante de ces
dernières de ces derniers jours et en
tout cas de ces dernières semaines vous
avez choisi Aurélien Pradier pourquoi
lui alors pas tellement pour lui parce
que on sait pas s'il va marquer la vie
politique dans les années à venir mais
il me semble le symptôme de quelque
chose de plus général qui est une sorte
de parlementarisme individualiste on a
61 députés LR des négociations j'y
reviens qui ont été très très longues
quand on fait bouger des milliards
d'euros entre le gouvernement et LR et
au final le groupe LR le parti LR
n'arrive pas à convaincre 17 sans doute
17 entre 15 et 20 peut-être 20 membres
de son groupe ce qui est vraiment le le
signe d'un rapport très très
individualiste au mandat on estime que
c'est sur sa bonne étoile sur sa
notoriété sur sa chance que on est
arrivé là où on est alors il y a
toujours eu de l'indiscipline
parlementaire mais là ça nous rappelle
un peu les années Hollande qui était
dans un contexte extrêmement différent
on voit que si la machine
institutionnelle se grippe c'est aussi
pour ça c'est aussi parce qu'il y a des
difficultés à gouverner collectivement
au sein d'un parti certaines
frondeurs c'est des auto-entrepreneurs
n'est pas mauvais je pense ça c'est
vraiment le petit bout de la lornette
excusez-moi de vous le dire comme ça
parce que comme pour les frondeurs je
pense que le débat qui se pose au Parti
socialiste comme au Républicain c'est le
fait de tourner la page de penser
autrement que les cadres du libéralisme
du néolibéralisme et les frondeurs c'est
à ça qui se sont attaqués ils ont
cherché à faire le gouvernement que la
politique appliquée de tant de Hollande
ne soit pas celle d'une politique
néolibérale et que les frondeurs du côté
des républicains cherchent à imaginer
une autre voix pour les républicains qui
ne soient pas libérales et parce que les
trois que l'on a cité enfin franchement
tous les chats sont gris enfin je veux
dire les trois prétendants de la droite
qu'il soit macronistes horizon ou LR
sont à peu près sorties du même moule la
question c'est ces deux grandes parties
de gouvernement les socialistes et les
républicains seront-ils capables
d'inventer un autre de sortir un autre
logiciel qu'un logiciel pure libéral je
crois que c'est ce qui est en train de
se passer dans le monde et je crois
qu'ils n'ont pas encore pris de cette
mesure et que c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
en train de se décongeler quelques
minutes je vais commencer à aborder un
thème qui sera le thème central de notre
second débat j'aurais quand même vous
entendre là-dessus sur la question du du
3 pardon l'article 49 3 de la
Constitution Franck Morel est-ce que
Elisabeth borne va prendre le risque là
tout le monde a sorti sa calculette vous
nous disiez le nombre de de députés LR
il faut pour que la réforme passe
alors moi mon opinion là-dessus c'est
que s'il s'avère dans les comptages qui
seront faits dans la dernière ligne
droite que il y a un vrai aléa
évidemment qu'elle ne prendra pas ce
risque donc elle passera par le 49
qu'elle utilisera le 49-3 ça me paraît
alors elle l'aurait voulu elle a tout
fait pour l'éviter et dans la séquence
elle a brûlé même ses cartouches dès le
début très tôt très tôt puisque dès la
présentation de la réforme a été mis en
avant le 64 plus accélération de
Touraine plutôt que le 65 parce que
précisément le but principal de cette
présentation c'était d'obtenir le vote
dès le début dès le début des
républicains et donc elle s'est mise en
situation plutôt de faire en sorte
d'obtenir un vote classique mais force
et elle a rappelé encore récemment
qu'elle ne se situait pas dans la
perspective du 49.3 qu'elle préférait à
votre classique mais je pense que dans
quand les pointages vont être faits par
les conseillers parlementaires à
Matignon et rue de Grenelle que ça se
joue à moins de 10 mois près je pense ne
prendra pas le risque le précédent
d'ailleurs il y a un précédent assez
intéressant c'était la loi Macron en
2015 où le 49-3 à l'époque avait été
utilisé par Manuel Valls parce que dans
la situation précisément à l'époque des
frondeurs le gouvernement de l'époque
n'avait pas voulu prendre le risque au
regard d'un aléa qui existait dans le
décompte de ne pas réussir à faire
adopter le texte furieux Emmanuel Macron
pendant furieux effectivement ce qui a
été un élément de un des un des éléments
de rupture avec Manuel Valls ce que lui
disait ma loi je peux la passer grâce au
mode classique
alors après dans le contexte
d'aujourd'hui effectivement le 49-3 est
fort probable bon il a été utilisé quand
même à 28 reprises je crois sous votre
contrôle par Michel Rocard en quatre
entre 88 et 93 dans un contexte de
majorité relative là évidemment c'est
beaucoup moins fréquent parce que depuis
on a resserré le prisme seulement sur
les textes de nature budgétaire en tout
cas où une fois ou un joker en tout cas
sur les autres mais en tout cas c'est
quelque chose qui est probable
effectivement vous le mot de la conclure
vous m'avez demandé tout à l'heure si
l'utilisation du vote bloqué délégitimer
le texte je me suis mouillé en vous
disant non si vous me posiez la même
question sur 49 3 je vais mourir en vous
disant oui pour une raison en partie
symbolique c'est-à-dire le 49.3 ça
marque on le voit dans les manifs il y a
des panneaux 49-3 oui votre bloqué ça
passe sous les radars de l'opinion c'est
quelque chose qui est identifié comme
tel ce que n'ignore pas le pouvoir donc
s'ils utilisent le 49-3 ils prennent
leur risque ils prennent leur risque de
de laisser penser qu'ils ont mené cette
réforme de manière autoritaire et assez
peu respectueuse du jeu démocratique
quand bien même on reste c'est pas un
coup d'état ça reste bien sûr autorisé
par la Constitution et l'une des
questions qu'on va aborder maintenant
notre second débat c'est la stratégie
syndicale en fonction effectivement du
choix du 49-3 ou pas merci beaucoup à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
premier